hello everyone and welcome to an
absolutely thrilling game from round two
of this year's Reykjavik open uh it is a
true legend of the chess Arena Simon
Williamson uh pretty much when I started
uh even before I started my chess
Channel some 10 years ago when I started
watching uh chess content on YouTube
when you only had like motto was doing
chess on YouTube Jerry from chess
network was doing John Bartholomew was
there one of the one of the people
already creating content was Simon
Williams and he he's a natural born
attacker he he loves attacking and his
games are always incredibly interesting
he uh he he pushed his H Pawn pretty
much in every game even before Alpha
zero made it cool so he really
understands how to attack and this is a
like a phenomenal attacking game he's
facing uh Anastasia women International
master from Ukraine she as I understand
it won the Ukrainian championship for
for girls and women uh 20 times over
different age categories so uh not not
going to be easy for Simon even though
there's a significant rating difference
that being said let's check it out I I
cannot wait for you guys to see this so
here Simon opens with the D4 we have D5
by Anastasia C4 we have C6 she goes for
the slav defense C capture Sun D5 Simon
goes for the exchange variation C
captures and Knight the C3 we have
Knight to F6 and here uh there are many
moves you can play here pretty standard
moves are Knight to F3 and Bishop to F4
uh but Simon played Pawn to F3 and when
I first saw this I thought okay probably
Simon is trying to get a nice win with
Pawn to F3 to promote some sort of
adjustable course he's creating how to
crush the slav with 5f3 uh but okay
let's see the game we have E6 uh we have
Pawn to E4 he grabs the full Center Pawn
captures Pawn captures and knights the
C6 so uh Anastasia just continuing
developing Knight to F3 and Bishop to B4
she now wants the castle to safety and
Simon plays this very tricky Bishop to
D3 move and now as you'll see it's not
that easy to Castle because if she just
castles Simon throws in a nice E5 and
after Knight the D5 already you can
resign Bishop captures on H7 and his
game over King captures Knight the G5
check it's a standard Bishop sacrifice
on H7 and queen uh will Checkmate the
black king or you give up the queen for
for the Knight here are also very
resignable so after Bishop to D3 she
played Bishop to A5 which is strong uh
she wants to uh shift the the bishop
over to B6 or to C7 Plus at some uh in
some lines you can even consider a move
like Knight to B4 Simon still goes for
E5 with knights the D5 and here there is
a game where Bishop to D2 was played
last year but here Simon plays castles
King side and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game and
okay he also sacrifices the pawn here so
she grabs it Knight captures on C3 B
captors and the bishop captures
attacking The Rook on A1 he goes Rook to
B1 and now Pawn to H6 again you can't
really Castle here with a castle Bishop
captures on H7 is just winning
again so Ponte H6 was played now Bishop
captures and H7 will no longer be an
option but now Simon has this very nice
Bishop to A3 move now the uh you might
think okay why play H6 in such a
position but it's very hard to find the
move here for black uh the only way to
try and play this is by playing Bishop
captures with check uh White will of
course move the king not capture you
will play Bishop captress on E5 then
comes Knight captures Knight captures
and now Bishop to B5 check and after
Bishop to D7 now Queen E2 will attack
the Knight and after the Knight moves
you will again Play Bishop to A3 uh
preventing the black king from castling
so the black king will have uh problems
uh this game but this this is this was
the best way to try and save the game
for Anastasia instead she played H6 and
okay Bishop to A3 now Simon completely
stops the the black king from escaping
Ponte A5 she's not now she's even
dreaming of of putting something on B
for just a just the the castle the the
blacking the safety but Simon goes for
Queen to A4 now of course the such moves
are impossible if you play Bishop B4
just Bishop captures and you will not be
able to capture Back The Rook honey 8
would hang so after Queen to A4 we have
Bishop to D7 now the Knight can move but
now look at this Rook captures on B7
Knight captures on D4 now opening up an
attack on Simon's Queen on A4 and you
could consider a lot of moves here for
example Queen to C4 is nice it's it's
very nice like they broke the C8 Queen
the C6 Queen to A6 and you retain all
the pressure yeah black really has
nothing to do here yeah eventually you
will win this game but Simon goes for
the uh absolutely uh thrilling idea and
that is Knight captures on D4 he
sacrifices his Queen on A4 and now you
realize that the black king really
uh really has no squares and that white
doesn't even need the queen to continue
this attack you have this bishop you
have this Rook you have this Rook you
have this bishop the Knight here on D4
also a viable attacker so here Bishop
captures on A4 was played you have to
capture the queen otherwise you have no
moves so Bishop captures an A4 was
played and now feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Simon while I
give you a couple of seconds there's
only one winning move here so uh do your
best
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh brilliancy and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
characters on E6 that's right you have
to sacrifice even more material uh
because that's how chess works and here
you you could easily resign here it
wouldn't be uh you know shameful or
anything uh but she continued with Queen
to H4 I will just show you what happens
if you play some other moves like if you
capture the bishop on D3 Rook D7 is
mating one so obviously you cannot move
the queen from the defense of the E7
square but capturing the Knight isn't
much better just Bishop to G6 is not
Checkmate look at this Mighty Bishop
pair and The Rook pair this is uh this
is something I I don't think I've ever
seen the bishop pair and The Rook pair
uh you know being used the such
Perfection maybe maybe an Anderson's
Immortal game uh but uh other than in
the Evergreen game story but other than
that I don't know so here after Knight
captures an E6 Queen the H4 was played
and this kinda keeps the game alive but
now comes Rook captures on F7 Rook Rook
from uh F1 captures on F7 uh Bishop to
B4 other moves don't really helpful that
much if you you could give one check
with Queen T1 but then Bishop to F1 can
just block in the game Bishop to B4 was
played kinda trying to stop this Bishop
from controlling E7 now Rook E7 is
impossible because you just capture with
the queen uh but you could play it you
could still play it pretty much every
move is winning here Simon played Rook
to f8 with check and he was in this
position unmove 20 that Anastasia
mangulova resigned in the game as there
is nothing more to be done here it's
just looking at this it it's absolutely
beautiful what Simon has created here
today and uh if he does create some sort
of adjustable course or something with
this F3 line I really hope everyone buys
it because I mean you you could also
create something like this at least once
in your life uh so the problem here is
if you capture The Rook it's not really
great if your captors you're just gonna
get mated into Bishop G6 check only move
Rook F7 and now Bishop captures will be
Checkmate or if you don't capture with
the Rook you could also capture with the
bishop but then Bishop G6 is mating one
so there you have it uh beautiful
beautiful attacking game by Simon and it
all uh you know became possible uh with
this F3 line it doesn't even have a name
it's just a line in the in the exchange
variation of the slot but after this
game I I would not mind it to be uh you
know uh called the the Williams line or
maybe even the the assignment so you
know if you guys play this uh I I you
know if if anyone doesn't mind I I if I
ever see it I will call it the Simon you
know uh it's that good uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh try
it maybe it works out for you as well
it's uh it's pretty cool attacking line
it's not very easy for black to Castle
as you've seen and white didn't really
have to do all that all that much to to
accomplish this so you know it's
trickier trickier than it looks I would
like to thank Ned Riley BB chess a
London system and Marcus Steele for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World hope more
games like this happen in the Chess
World see you soon